哇崩潰了
今天台灣股市
哇一度跌2000多點
哇歷史前幾大的跌點
都在這幾天出現了
台股跌破42000
只是剛開始嗎
投資朋友
剛才永豐發出一個
融資追剿令的一個提醒
告訴你
41250點差不多啦
再跌個400點
就會大量的融資追剿斷頭
會不會只是剛開始
第二個
中國自研半導體設備
是大力控嗎
最近好多假消息
好多新消息
被動員件斬價啦
太陽又電啦
又使大家進產啦
這個聽說是斬價的函啦
是假消息
還有
哲哲說
就是我
破四萬點
我要砸一億
哲哲基金要進產
我一切
我就可能預告在前面
老天爺要送錢給我花
我就花
借錢
怎么又崩盘啦
台股今天崩了2030点
最后收跌在41603点
真的正式破底了
竟然跌破42000
真的是天崩地裂
今天下跌加速有1632加
而跌停加速也来到96加
今天国具真的很惨
从高点的1220元
到今天只剩下563元
真的是腰斩了
而投资产最强最抗跌的环球金和金财也都跌停
投资朋友们最近的心情仿佛就像是在洗三温暖
每天都七上八下的
究竟问题到底出在哪里呢
难道是因为今天韩国又又又熔断了吗
还是因为中国在研发半导体设备
而导致台股受到牵连呢
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍單季188%的紀錄保持著
投資者是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
李李 各位你們大家好
今天一堆留言說哲哲救我
我救你
破四萬點 我會咋一意
投資朋友 就算我借錢
我都會拿出一意來
但叔叔練過
你們以現金all in
我知道你還有錢
借這件事情
這幾年研究AI的發展
我看你等一下也做很沾圖
是
你現在
我跟你講
我現在給你看技術線圖
我可以告訴你很醜啦
大盤線圖就是
基本上你找不到支撐點位啦
因為季線破了嘛
你季線破了
你不要說哲哲
我求半連線
半連線要幹嘛
半連線我要看一下
240MA
你要幹嘛
你半連線跌破
看連線要幹嘛
不需要嘛
不是不是
這是連線
等我一下
連線 連線太遠了
半連線
半連線的時候我看39000
半連線不錯
就是可能我想要進場的點位
不要不要不要
你們不要想那麼多
這邊就基數線型來講的話
沒有支撐
這講的話很實在
因為乾破基數
乾怎麼樣
第一個
破季線
乾破季線
這邊拉起來拉起來
突破 再次跌破 這常常可以
而且這次的低點比上次的低點還低
是
底部越墊越低的你知道嗎
高膽越來越低 底部也越來越低
底底低 高高低
就是底部越來越低
高膽也越來越低 有沒有看到
高膽越來越低 有沒有看到
是不是
是
所以這個是很典型的
目前看起來下跌沒有支撐的一個行情
第二個
我們在畫這邊的頸線有沒有看到
這邊是有個頸線
有
來喔
這邊僅限不就4萬2嘛
我說4萬2不能跌破
我說4萬2有支撐
結果連支撐都沒有
哲哲你怎麼看
我之前也講過了
4萬2沒有破
4萬2破的話
到4萬點
現在已經開始要融資追角令了
因為前陣子跌到4萬2的時候
比如說台股股有些融資維持率不足嗎
為什麼融資維持率不足
最近韓國去槓桿
台灣也在去槓桿
韓國的那個SK
還有三星的ETF
政惡嘛對不對
政惡不是什麼政惡手術
但他們現在也就經歷政惡手術了
是 真的
那個四條站
等一下投稿可以寫這文章
經歷過政惡手術
是不是
政惡手術你一段時間只能吃流池
一看就知道沒有經過政惡手術你知道嗎
不然不會下巴還那麼長
好不好
至於於人
來啦
經過正...就是調整下巴的正二手術
韓國也經過正二手術
這個韓國的正二手術
到這個月底
好像到31號吧
全部保證金要全部繳完
保證金提高了嘛對不對
是
現在就太多殺多了
因為有些人繳不出來我就斷頭
所以韓國亂搞
韓國經常會亂搞
台灣的就不會
台灣就不會
台灣就不錯
我們該保守的時候要保守一點
是
好 那我會說
那這個韓國政客手術
經過一告之後
扁稅最慘的7月底
我有可能明天運氣好的話
我明天就跌破4萬點
蛤 哲哲什麼叫運氣好
你有沒有看過
我今年計較還是很猛
只是我沒有賣在高點而已
我搞清楚他一件事情
蛤哲哲
你是4萬點
那你還進場
你才進場
你敢進場
沒有辦法
我不經常你又念我
第二個
蛤蛇
那你真的要買1嗎
這個說話算話
買1就買1
好不好
OK嗎
就買1
至少買1
好不好
就算你不用管蛇的直徑來源
就算去借我也處理
好不好
可是我不建議你就借
我說我的意思告訴我
我的心態
那蛇蛇為什麼不現在買
我的心態很簡單
其實現在買你也可以啊
只是
就幾乎現行的話
它是有可能跌破四萬點
蛇蛇你要今天先賣
明天再買
你懂我
你懂我什麼
你懂我是神還是神棍
沒有人是神
那只有神棍而已
我今天賣我明天馬上買
我不知道低檔在哪裡啦
現在就破線我不知道
可是破四萬點
老天爺要送錢給我花
我就砸嘛
一一啊
很快就可以八萬點了啦
五年內甚至四年內十萬點
等於一一變兩一五
天啊
那要不要
當然要
要啊
所以同學朋友
你今天不要緊張
這可能是你今年最後加碼點
我要再講的是
我是全台灣最敢喊點數的
最準的
所以那時候我不是說
同志朋友你不要喊五萬點
哇 我一定要什麼
我不是要批評人家
我現在要我不是要批評人家
因為很多人喊
我說你不要只是喊五萬點
因為喊五萬點
大家會失去的風險意識
而且你要講什麼時候會風險意識
可是你不能講那麼短的一節點
可是如果你說拉長一點
我可以告訴你
今年我覺得很有機會
你懂不懂
今年很有機會
可是你不能說短時間內我們要上5萬點
我說這樣子會失去的風險意思
我在強調一件事情
五年內甚至四年內會上10萬點
請你把我這一句話記起來
記起來
可是我要先強調一下
我是合法分析師
因為最近很多網紅害死大家
之前就讓大家借錢
今天都不敢講了好不好
很多不敢講
都非法的好不好
非法集團
都不敢講了
我郭哲龍
你告訴我我當分析師
什麼時候叫你借錢買股票
Never
Forever
這一波就是去槓桿洗那些愛融資的人
那是他媽
不管你的事啊
那是他媽 不管你的事
我再強調一件事
如果在十萬點面前
你管他是四萬三 四萬一 四萬點
我買四萬點只要買得漂亮
那有可能沒有到四萬點啊
那我就少賺一億多吧
那也沒關係
我不在乎啊
就像之前不是有人在那邊亂詭謊我嗎
我說我告
他們都不相信我會告
告到現在一年兩年過去的我還是要告
不管他我是花幾十萬幾百萬律師費
我就不在乎
他們自己不了解我
搞到自己身體不好
我也心疼啊
你幹嘛被我告
是不是
然後告來告去
你還不是攻擊我還不是為了自己的利益
然後搞到自己呢
身體不好是完膜玻璃
哇 心臟開大大
是不是
業績也衰退
那財報都知道
業績都知道事情
沒必要
我郭忠說話就說話
我要讓你知道我的毅力
破四萬點
我就是要進場
我自己有雜意
分譯是不能買股票啦
不太能買股票啦
所以我最沒有真意
就買台灣50
好不好
OK嗎
這我要跟大家講
我
我不知道
對不起握大舌頭
因為今天我要講的東西很多
我今天認真做很多東西
你們看一下
你們看這個影片
看一下有沒有雜音
看一下
氣死了
有有有
等一下
你看那個聲音還沒出來嘛
對這邊
你看現在就有一個女朋友了
現在很多人用確確必遞罪話
就是其實就是
你在講話的時候
他會插你的話
很像對話 你聽他講話
來聽一下
看聲音有沒有問題
小伊
因為你跟我講 你看
莉莉這個女生不輸你喔
來
很漂亮
很漂亮 你也很漂亮啦
好 她不輸你來
來什麼出嫁子喔
這個字也很厲害
給大家看一下
我的微博客廳在SYB6
現在要跟他講話了喔
你好啊 霞雅
你好喔 霞雅有沒有看到
今天過得怎麼樣
過得怎麼樣喔
靠杯啦 你終於上線了
我既開心又有點怨你
嗯 小雅一個人在這裡等你
等的都快委屈死了
你個大模型 你委屈個得兒啊你
不想來就不聊囉
本來是什麼臭架子喔
這個自己很厲害
不想來就不聊囉
你看他說
他叫他說你是個模型
他就說你不想他就不想你
這個人像真的人
我跟你講喔 這反應還比較慢喔
Jerman來 確局比例反應很快
會讓你更像真人
你知道Jerman來現在已經有對話了喔
比如說一個女生對不對
對 有澳洲女生
因為現在女生常常強調是沒有情緒價值
你知道沒有情緒價值
哇 他就說假算對話
有個女生喔
假算對話說
就跟Jerman來講話
他設定他是男生
設定他中和老實的男生
你去重訓啊
啊 妳是重訓 如果女生搭訕妳
男生說 不會有女生搭訕我
會啊 女生搭訕妳
問妳要幾組 妳要怎麼回答
三組吧
三組不行啊 妳為什麼要這樣回答
女生會生氣喔
那男生說 喔 那怎麼辦呢
那她說
妳就跟她講說
當女生問妳有幾組
要重訓的時候幾組 還是要幾組的時候
妳就跟她講說 我要問我女朋友
男生怎麼回答 很可愛啊
妳是認真的嗎
哇 好像真人喔
然後他說對 我一直在講
好好好
那女生說好 那我們訓練一次
假設我現在要搭訓你
問你有幾組要重訓 還剩幾組
好 那你請問一下你還有幾組
不好意思
他說不好意思 我等一下問我女朋友
他這樣講
接不來 要不要去GPT 很像真人
這個拜託
我跟你講 AI 的造化
我昨天要研究一下
研究一下為什麼越來越多的
諾貝爾得主
說十年內所有的癌症
大部分癌症可以克服
所有嗎
他說大概百分之八十九十癌症
因為很多癌症這樣子
哇 我有免疫的藥物得過以後
它會逃脫
逃脫了以後
因為蛋白質它等於是有點動態的
因為不然是有點動態的
其實簡單來講
這個也很專業
不好意思 這不是我專業
可是我可以簡單來講
你這些針對這些癌症
它就是一個蛋白質的一些成分
你要針對不同的成分
是
就像 正講一下
幾萬個鑰匙 他們有個鑰匙
幾萬個鑰匙
你這個就是一個門把
要從幾萬把鑰匙裡面選出一個鑰匙
以前針對這個蛋白質
針對癌症蛋白質的成分
你要選出一個最適合的藥物
你要盲測盲測 現在不必了AI可以在短暫時間內從十幾年的時間發展到幾個月甚至幾天時間內選到最對的藥物
來針對這個癌症
官是肺癌
它其實就有可能幾十種的
癌症不同
那你懂我意思嗎
不是肺癌就是肺癌
你懂不懂
是
就像你看
大家不是說血癌很恐怖
對
是不是
你看那個
沈玉琳
為什麼他的血癌藥
就有笑了
因為剛好
它剛好它的血癌是某種免疫藥物
可以怎樣
可以救火的
你懂意思嗎
那以前
那所以雖然是肺癌
或雖然是很多血癌
它其實有很多不同的腫瘤
不同的成分
那這些以前都沒辦法
都要測好幾年 幾十年
可是現在不是
像AI
在短短時間內
我昨天不是跟妳講說一個什麼
一個數學猜想嗎
87年沒有破解
我講的東西是要告訴你
等同於一些
其實蛋白質的成分
這些解藥
等同於化學的方程式一樣
找出一個最適合的解
一個數學猜想
87年都沒有數學家
不論智商多高
可能智商180 200以上
也解不開這樣的問題
可是現在
一個AI就可以了
AI無遠佛界
我要講一件事情
我不是因為政治人物
喜不喜歡
我覺得這就滿好笑的
我在跟你講大海
你在跟我講出口杯
在講這兩點
我怕你們不喜歡好不好
我其實覺得蠻酷的啦
好笑
蠻白的蠻好笑的
我要跟大家講就是說
現在我看是10萬點
然後不講這個
講這個大家覺得政治意涵
對不起收回
說10萬點
你們給我看10萬3 10萬1
我管那麼多
沒有破10萬你就不買
就算了
我本來就有買很多
台灣50
納斯達克的ETF
夠了
我跟你講的是
我本來隨時就可以退休了
你不用擔心我
我是為你們服務啊
我沒有去在乎這個
我自己有沒有賺錢
我沒有那麼在乎啦
真的要上去也沒關係
你們也賺到錢的啊
我也開心啊
真的下去呢
哇更好
因為遲早你們還是會賺到錢
很大機率你們還是會賺到錢
然後我也賺到
然後我本身還有原本的部位
我也賺到
三贏啊
沒有了也沒關係
酸贏嘛
因為你們還是賺到錢的
你們不會痛苦那麼久
OK嗎
沒有跌破四萬點
你們代表你們沒有痛苦那麼久嘛
對不對
然後第二個
我原本的部位好像50部位
納斯達克ETF部位
我也賺錢
雙贏
下去呢
我最新部位也就賺錢
好不好
很多人可以低接更賺錢
就這樣子
你們今天
真的不要解了好不好
拜託你先看看中美金跌停
環球金跌停
你看環球金
環球金這根只是很誇張
因為我在1000元附近有買
今天給我跌停
可是我覺得他太誇張了啦
他太誇張了
可是我還是有很多
很多是買很低的
我很多會員還是滿很低的
所以我告訴你一件事情
時間點很重要
你現在買的
我不得不說
我比較對不起
是上個月參加我會員的
的會員們
可是我告訴你
你相信我今年就是會破5萬點
我這件事情相信我今年會破5萬點
來四亞再給我那個
昨天那個東森的那個財經主播
的個人催
12月的時候多少人吐槽我
說只有我敢喊那個點數
到了4萬多點
每個銀行5萬6萬幹什麼
我反而說你要小心謹慎
我今天要告訴你
點數我最敢喊
時間點我最準
不要去管那些東西
我看的是未來
我看的是 future
看了這個你不會開心的
黃永鑫記錄線型能看嗎
可以你看黃永鑫你不開心
除非你什麼
除非你順便看一下國劇
發現比較開心
對不對
沒有比較沒有傷害
沒有比一比較就覺得好開心啊
真的
對國劇沒有比較沒有三大
我們一比較就我們賺到了
國劇好慘了
所以國劇真的不會到1200
好不好
至少今年看起來不會到1200啦
算上我萬點不會到
因為大家因為現在大家都討論喔
我大家說哇
國劇的悲劇要問整個就好
我是有點
不要說我不是被他割酒菜
我被他割了一半而已啦好不好
因為我是從兩三百塊做算去的
那時候經濟日報巡述
技術保持者就是我啦
好不好
就一半
我被他割到了
好不好
因為下去的時候我受傷了
韓運股那時候後來
2021年開始韓運股也是
像國具這樣子
國具已經第二次這樣子喔
這一次更長而已
三型走勢有沒有看到
聖誕數走勢好不好
OK嗎 聖誕數走勢嗎
真的
聖誕數有沒有
三型走勢
那時候韓運股的2.0
就是不是韓運股
國具2.0就韓運股的時候
我那時候就避開了
避得不錯
避得不錯 我就七進七出
還是有些賠到
可是最後有部分把它賺回來
我假設上去下來的時候
我不想左側
左側我會賺很兇
這次國具我出得漂亮
賺100%啦
漂亮
連發科不要不要
漂亮啦
你們不要在那邊
連發科也正式要破
連發科平均出來4000元以上
現在3300
可是我跟你講
看這些你不會開心啊
除非你現在看看聯發科
我看一看國具你就很開心
我現在相對比他們強
可是真的不會開心啊
最強的精彩都殺下去了
有沒有
莫名其妙
基本上要200多塊我要買
精彩的好處是
其實現在反而好處是
你要你要
你有怎麼樣
你有一個更漂亮的甜味
我再講一件事情
你記得我的名言
你知道什麼叫我
我台哲哲我有很多名言
譬如說
我沒有說賭博不好
但你不能騙自己在投資
這句話也很盛行
是
打到人家心裡面
對
可是有一句話最紅是什麼
我知道
你還有錢
我知道你還有錢
你們不要到時候
又找到五萬點說
對哲哲我還有錢
你現在就把錢拿出來
只要現金
就給他all in啦
all in啦
相信我
all in
你會謝謝我
你會愛我
分散投資然後all in
你真的也會愛上我
就算是男生你都會喜歡上我
帥
有錢錢就給他all in
AI太恐怖了
我剛才簡直解釋那個
醫學的人就比較了解我會說什麼
可是前提是你還會用AI
好不好
你一個數學猜想
智商不能多高升級數學家
那數學系的天才沒有一個解得出來
你要簡單簡單一個反例
相反的例子證明這個
字質不成立
找了87年找不出來
藥物也是一樣啊
現在還找那種三中因子
你知道我昨天看了好多
看了很多 paper 好累
我不是醫學系的
三中因子
他就是說那你的細胞活化
是
那你細胞活化
現在打眼睛
有些人瞎掉了
打青棺眼
因為青棺眼瞎掉了
看可不可以活化
6月開始實驗了
好不好
所以以後會更多的這種AI
選出來更好的這種
三中英子
那你的細胞活化
你有1000億的身家
我問你啊
砸200億啊
那你年輕10歲要不要
我要啊
哎
哲哲財報不好
我理你喔
看財報幹什麼
最好就是2008年的時候
在開始看財報
哎
你們在幹什麼
你們就覺得Google是白癡就對了是不是
會把自己搞到破產是不是
人家每天穩定的現金流
只是現在入不敷出
他現金流假設我有1000億美金
那我丟個1500億支出不行喔
你覺得他是白癡到都不能借錢
沒有要借他是不是
你就Google Microsoft都是一樣嗎
Microsoft現在要租借算利啊
不夠就不夠啊
好 我說你講那機器人跳舞
那全部是全面爆發啊
全面爆發 我要講全面爆發
你真的要開心有這種回答
因為去掉這些槓桿
那些人本來很大一部分借錢的人
他本來就屬於不會財富
不會財富自由的人
一開始觀念錯誤了
我再問你一次
我郭子龍至少有沒有講過100次
不要去借錢
有
我看這講一件事
這邊真的跌破示範點
我會exciting
我告訴你
真的exciting
真的好不好
我真的感到很興奮
我是跟你說真的好不好
真的真的
我看大家留言
真的
來
我看先賣掉拿出來花掉吧
花的掉就財產
花不掉就移償
這句話我講過沒錯
你現在花就遜掉了
你要說你47,000
你真的賣到高點就算了
我跟你講代表
去年要再加碼嗎
很多股票想加碼好不好
不一定要群年好不好
今天都賣掉
我等穩定再接
我要睡得安穩
我跟你講一件事
如果你們
我看起來你們好瘋狂
好緊張
剛才不是有人這樣講
哇今天我都賣掉
我要等我睡得掉
才安穩
基本上融資的人就會睡不安穩
因為他睡不好覺
是
可是我告訴你
你為什麼要做二分法
你真的覺得你會買低點嗎
你會後悔
你今天賣掉股票
我不敢說百分之百
因為我是合格分析師
沒有什麼事一定
可是我告訴你
你會後悔
你如果今天有壓力
你賣得掉
那你就先賣三分之一嗎
不行
你再賣一半嗎
這不行你再賣2 3分之2嘛
這不行你再全賣嘛
讓我全賣
我這要進產
你就問一下郭子宏的
郭子宏台灣50勝率多少
目前為止公開勝率過去的喔
100%
未來我不知道
過去100%
真的啦
好不好
國際前年更誇張好像沒有人要的東西
前年是
他前年最後打開跌停啊
其實我跟你說真的
要不是最後打開點
要不是
要不是我不能買股票
我是真的
其實想買股票賺比較快
因為台灣股市跌不多
是
你知道嗎
你看這種股票
到時候
你看如果群聯我在
你看你看以前也是
2670跌到1640元
假設這邊對不對
對
我們算一下
2670到1640算一下
1640除以2670
等於多少
今天回答大概38%
也還好
大概三五法則差不多
好
那如果我們從多少
從2670到1640
對不對好不好
從1640
從1640到
就從現在突破新高
除以1640
我們是賺62%
是
下去38%
上去62%
這點是嗎
下去
38%
沒有錯吧
同樣的價位上去
62%
只有金錢的魅力
你知道嗎
你們現在坐空或空手
等於你們在侮辱台積電
你們在侮辱台積電
幾萬名以上的員工
你們在侮辱他
你們在侮辱全世界在研究AI的人
就是AI泡沫啊
AI不一定有獲利啊
我就覺得你們看好錢
我再給你做個報告
這我今天做很多
我今天跌的時候反正就文思全有
自己也做一些報告
然後叫思雅幫我們做一下
那看一下
來
我跟你講網路泡沫跟AI泡沫差別你知道嗎
以前網路泡沫這樣打打看啦
哇 取一個網路或什麼
有一個網路兩個字喔
他就馬上怎麼樣
馬上賺錢 馬上上市
你看Enthorpeak他還不敢上市
有沒有看到
到現在沒有辦法上市
限制在反而是輕人營收毛利
自由現金的量
比如輝達跟台積電有沒有看到
領頭也還算是賺錢
對
以前網路泡沫是很多還沒賺錢
有沒有看到
而且變現滲透度
你要先鋪關鮮
買PC
然後辦撥接器
滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴
你沒聽過對不對
沒有耶
我老了我怎麼辦
不好意思
我沒聽過是小人跟我講的
對
好 現在沒有
現在直接可以覆蓋雲端跟手機有沒有看到
所以幾天內也可以覆蓋數譯的
是不是 所以那時候不是去年很容易
去年底不是開始很容易養龍蝦嗎
anthropic有沒有
從0到10億美金有沒有看到
有沒有看到
是
這個營收好不好
AR就是一個年度經常性的收入有沒有看到0到10億是8個月 從來沒有這樣子傳統軟體公司要到7到10年以前雲端
0到10億基本上是不可能的
你懂不懂意思
傳統軟體公司7到10年是很賺錢的
它現在18個月
所以我覺得像AI的爛槽
甚至有時候怎麼樣
是直線性的
成長是直線性的
所以營收這樣成長算正常
我們說AI成長是這樣直線性的嗎
所以以前要到10億美金
是很優秀的公司要到10年
Enthopic只要一年半
所以現在AI變現很快
誰說AI不能變現
AI絕對不會有泡沫
AI股會不會泡沫
我們要以這個由的討論
這講是AI絕對不會有泡沫
什麼意思
就算網路有泡沫
那現在誰不用網路
那懂嗎
好 可是AI股會不會泡沫
目前為止剛開始泡沫什麼東西啊
莫名其妙
所以我才說十萬點
懂不懂
十萬點以後你才說泡沫
十萬點以內拉回
用力買
拉回用力買
拉回用力買啊各位
我看到說買一億以內一億上了
我就說就算借錢我要買了
我已經講得很含蓄人
應該說明顯暗示你了
聽不懂
我看你剛剛那段有點緊張
緊張什麼莫名其妙
自鐵粉都會開心啦好不好
聽得懂波階聲音的人
以前都波及上網電源費很貴好不好
各國很多跌停只剩台積線沒跌停
所以你現在你反而是要買那些跌停的股票
買那些跌停機優股好不好
國巨再跌下去我反而絕可以買
只是他們 國巨
這你不是每天買國巨
買進國巨 公園相聚
叫稅公園
來
我管他 你跌到400塊
假設我跌到400塊對不對
我很簡單啊 我談到800就好啦
800這邊啊
我談到800個位
談到800啊
一倍啊
為什麼不行
你們這斷頭
最好斷頭斷頭斷頭
那些人最好斷頭
謝謝
我們要去
我姊姊雖然這樣講很討厭
但我會回饋社會
我會去救護車好不好
我會回饋社會
軍救護車好不好
我跟你講
現在最討厭的不是我
最討厭的是
現在才罵那些借錢的人
前陣子一堆網紅叫人借錢
一堆人
我沒有
分析師也不會像我這樣說
哎 不要借錢啦
因為他這樣會減少業績
我不在乎啦
關鍵是你們這樣真的賣的會後悔啦
真的啦
這時候我這樣馬上沒錢的
我這樣你還有錢
好不好
沒錢沒關係放著好不好
OK嗎
沒錢就放著好不好
好不好
看看今天直播人數
6800也沒有想像中多6900
我以為今天會破1萬
樊軒今天手建都買到
樊軒很強欸
今天只要沒有跌停了
之前漲很多
樊軒
之前一直漲
樊軒很強
你看成天這麼走勢算很強對不對
對啊
他算強了
有沒有看他既然沒有跌停算強了好不好
最強的是微星啦
微星趕快買好不好
有兩種股票要買
一個是完全不跌的股票
你要確定是沒跌一段了
完全不跌的股票趕快買
因為有時候沒跌掉
最後不跌的股票最後反而加速下跌
是
然後另外一種是
本來要創新高的
結果被籌碼用亂的
黃球金
如果今天喔
如果今天是那個
我手上一億
我可以買股票
我其中一檔股票
我一定會買環球金
我說如果
你聽懂嗎
你聽懂我的意思嗎
如果
因為我跟你講
因為我覺得環球金很容易賺一倍
懂我意思嗎
啊只是群聯呢
群聯我也想買
可是群聯記憶體畢竟漲很多
群聯算記憶體裡面漲比較少了
是
可是我覺得矽晶圓的題材
才剛開始而已
這樣懂嗎
understand
環球金
然後金材一疊的話
我會再買金材
還有那個
微星
好不好
不是其他股票不好
是有限資金
我要找一個彈最快的
這樣懂不懂
曹志祥
你對大家也太好了吧
沒有關係
他們不敢買
他們不知道什麼點位
我是唐太宗
李世民的弟弟
唐太快
要是唐很快的話
你們拜託
就時候崇拜我
我跟你講我也說過我很大一筆的實質型的一天
啊我現在跌下去
我也受害者
為什麼笑笑的
欸我不是演的喔
我剛才進來的時候錄影的時候還要唱歌耶
我唱什麼歌我忘記了
唱什麼
你記不記得
你沒注意聽喔
沒注意聽
小紅唱什麼歌
只是
亂講不是這樣唱
一一唱什麼
忘記了
好像哼歌而已
哼歌喔
哼歌我不知道哼什麼
我已經滿很high
沒什麼
哎呀
你看喔
你不覺得只得越戳越有那種
你看國具那時候被他割韭菜
割一半韭菜
現在反而每天
甚至誰被誰割不知道
好不好
請叫我哥哥好不好
哥就是那個
我哥別人韭菜
沒有啦不是我哥哥
是他
是國具哥你韭菜
哥哥是那個
割韭菜哥
好啦
扯遠的啦好不好
OK
這跟大家講好不好
股
股市下跌不可能
最可怕的是很多人一直給你希望
沒有 我從頭到尾的時候有可能破10萬喔
反正沒關係啦
現在很多人不相信我沒關係
我都習慣了
你們最後還是發現者子的股市贏家
我每次財富都這樣賺進來了
欸 記得喔
我出社會的時候只有10萬塊喔
我只有10萬塊喔
大部分的錢還是我當那個
考上那個預官輔導長的時候
給的錢
來
者子今天桌子好可憐
還好還沒敲很大利
好不好
者子這一波金銅股都很看跌
拉回可以買金銅股啊
不要就是買AI股
All in
這是All in
你不All in
你會後悔
這大帥哥
我目前全部All in
這樣可以嗎
可以
最遜的
最爛的
就是你All in
定存
活存
受險
保險
不要
All in 050
你會參考會員
你可能不會啊
你All in
可能環球經營才會參考會員
I don't care
我來交朋友了
知道嗎
All in
好不好
國際更沒那個價值
我國際的那個
我也做一個畫面
給你看
你看我
你看我們這anthropic AI爛槽
跟2000年網路泡沫差很多
你看我做的圖很漂亮
來
太陽右電
載傳怎麼樣
調展MLCC錢無法保證交期對不對
這是moneyDJ的新聞
其實應該是假新聞
你看喔
漲價無法保證交期聽起來很厲害對不對
疑似造假
為什麼
這是我AI做的圖喔
通知書疑點多處無文法錯誤
不符合日文慣用文法
发布范围
仅出现在中文圈媒体
日文圈有可能没有展示消息吗
有可能吗
不太可能吧
太多人在公园相聚
想出来烂消息
买进国具
公园相聚
造假消息
我们搜寻
太阳诱店MLCC
完全没有日文新闻
有没有看到
是太阳诱店的社长
是
太阳诱店春天制作所
是被动原件的
日本被动原件大厂
所以他们想要靠这个假消息
应该是假消息
我先強調一件事
應該是假的
二型
可是查出來
太陽又有電MCC漲價
只有台灣新聞有
自由財經也用到了
這個也不能怪他們
就是網路的看起來太真了
來
太陽又有電這新聞有沒有看到
哇 寫太直白跟私底
不符合日本人的書信用信
有沒有看到
現在狀況怎麼樣啊
什麼努力啊
還要怪別人有沒有看到
有沒有看到
他文法錯誤啊
金額價格改定底
這個不好意思
因為好像
不好意思我們有日文專家
四瑤好像是N1還是N2
對 很厲害
簡定的啦 好不好
後面應該要接名詞
但詞細後面接動詞
我請問你啦
一個斬價書
你斬價就算了
還一堆文法錯誤
你不會想要被他尻下去喔
日本人講話都是很
很嚴謹的
福間福間是誰
OK嗎
是不是
而且怎麼會首途營業所
應該是怎麼會單一地區的營業所
雖然AI可以造假很多土偽你知道嗎
是不是
沒有錯吧
沒錯
這看起來太多問題了
他寫得很直白很私理
他形容詞也這個錯而已
後面
行容詞後面應該接名詞
不是接動詞
懂不懂
文法錯誤一堆啦
所以只有台灣新聞有
你看
這也是用AI去挑釁這錯誤
其實有人說過以前是AI是放大氣
放大你的情緒
為什麼有些AI跟那個男生討論
跟那個AI跟談戀愛以後
越談越開心
因為你個性是開心的
憂鬱的人談一談你會不想
你會受不了人生
所以我覺得太悲觀了
你不要跟AI談心
好不好 OK嗎
像我是不信這種東西的
好
我是沒有相信這種東西
所以我也不想跟AI講話
因為我自己知道
我跟自己講話比較實在
我常常跑完步
我跟自己對話
我要是什麼人生這樣子
真的
那其實AI是放大器
就是你邏輯好
你會用AI的人
那你就是很多
你就是用到很多
你不覺得我現在有AI東西
我有AI的系統後
有AI的軟體後
你不覺得我資訊跟人家不太一樣嗎
是
差更多
我們本來 我們某個頭顧本來就是
頭顧裡面最大的
然後我們有各式各樣
你看到的頭性啊
外資的報告我們本來都有
那其實就砸了不少錢
可是加上我們的AI
加上我們用AI
這點是好
AI是個泛大器
所以你要去學得用AI
如果你什麼
你平常都不去念書
不去用什麼事情的話
那至少你要投資我
你懂嗎
懂
就是以後AI可以讓一個人
以一擔白
能力強的人可以以一擔白
你要懂得會用AI問題
你懂嗎
OK嗎
所以你看這個也是我們告訴你
太陽右電MLCC漲價以交期的分析
你看我們做圖不覺得很漂亮嗎
疑似造假訊息
這也是用AI圖做的
然後用AI查處真假
AI可以做很多
哎呀中國自製DUV曝光機量產
這為了疊而疊啦
怎樣自製DUV喔
怎樣7nm內喔
這又手科是不是
這又用手科喔
這張索柯你知道嗎
這我相信喔
頂尖的材料
你覺得只要產DUV就好
上面的材料日本人不賣他材料可以嗎
你說我沒有曝光機
台積電那麼厲害是因為他們有DUV曝光機
是不是有曝光機
有愛世摩ASML的曝光機
說我自己生產就好啦
就可以贏台積電的啊
就可以生產晶圓的啊
謝謝公密
那曝光機也要有原料啊
是
曝光機還是要有原料啊
人家原料
人家歐美先進國家不賣你怎麼辦
中國算很厲害
但是曝光機沒那麼簡單啦
這個新聞聽得懂
其實很多是要給你們的線圖
很多股票像跟什麼
跟台股一樣
美國股市比如輝達也是一樣都破底
他都這樣ABC B波反彈
反彈
A波 B波反彈
C波下沙
破前波低點
所以才沙下去
他們都破前波低點
破前波大量結合區的低點
就這樣所有的股市
韓國 日本 台灣
就這樣子基礎線圖
看著線圖都醜啊
我不要小鼻子小眼睛我今天賣了
你怎麼知道明天會拉上去
我真的不知道
我只知道破四萬點
老天爺要送我兩億
我就花
我就賺啦
你拜託
你們不要謝忌的不要看我節目
真的 我不喜歡人生太悲觀
我不怪你們
只能說你們跟財富自由沒有相關
但我要強調一件事
這很低下去你也不要怪指責
因為指責會賠得比你多
好不好
可是我覺得我贏的機率很高
OK
對啊 DUV跟EUV
對啊
OK
來來
摩爾融資部門可以貸款嗎
不要鬧 不要融資啊
講笑話好不好
來
公園在滿的人
很喜歡聽者的解釋說分析
現在說為什麼全球股市都殺
你看那國際股市你看
是不是
是不是這條線都破了
是
你看這台灣股嘛對不對
對
我還說這條線
前波低一點都破了嗎
都破了嘛
所以說多殺多嘛
很多人是不是看基礎線圖啊
這怎麼懂
你懂吧
懂
然後我再畫粗一點
動一下
好 這台灣股市韓國股市有沒有看到今天為什麼殺10%也是啊前波低點本來有反彈反彈有亮耶前波低點殺下去的有沒有看到
還用跳空殺下去的
他今天最慘的是用跳空
跳空直接鐵破前波低點
好慘喔
這鐵破低點有沒有
跳空直接鐵破
這是大技術分析的大技啊
大技啊
你這個這邊的最
這邊這個區間整理平台
的最低點
在這邊
你直接跳空比這邊還低的低點開盤
但是一路殺
你要嘛就把它拉起來
沒有一路拉就會殺下去
就是很簡單
就大家看到技術分析
加上籌碼面
我正二
我SK 海力士 三星
正二
正二手術
正二沒有
正兩倍的ETF
我保證金要提高到7月底之前
提高不了
我自己斷手斷腳
它自己斷掉
去看我的鐵粉裡面
應該99%他沒在用融資的
像真的機會
拜託你們真的有閒錢
拜託
我真的很討厭
到時候我真的常常去才跟我
我很討厭到時候
你們拜託你們今天就要跟我講的
尤其是我會員
你粉絲我沒有辦法管你
因為你畢竟不是我會員
是會員的
拜託你已經看到我今天節目
拜託你有閒錢的
賴我一下
你有閒錢的賴我一下
真的
我還有錢
你一定還有錢的
很多人一定還有錢的
好不好
所以這邊就是紀錄分析
我只是剛好正式破底
就以為有反彈結果都沒有彈
你知道嗎
櫃滿指數也是要櫃滿指數為什麼差
櫃滿指數也是要
A波殺下去
B波反彈
C波下殺
而且前波低點
實體的或者是虛線都破了
就這麼簡單
基數分區這麼簡單
不要把它複雜化好不好
然後我們看一下日本走勢
都是一樣
有沒有
是不是最低的那邊
這邊嘛
對
今年跌破啦
今年跌破所以越殺越兇嘛
這邊套牢區域
這邊最低點今年跌破來了沒有
這邊是最低點
是
這裡跌破了
前一個月的四五月的
五六月的低點都破了
就這麼簡單的技術分析好不好
你不要去想那麼複雜
哎呀呀呀什麼東西
人家也會看技術分析懂不懂
國外也會看技術分析懂嗎
我們看廢棒指數
非常指數還是說
可是因為日本
我們這次跟韓國股是相連性比較高
所以看這些非常指數可不可以救台股
你懂不懂 OK嗎
可是你看納斯達克指數有沒有看到
可是現在小納應該是跌
小納這個科也跌破了有沒有看到
這一波也跌破了有沒有看到
是不是
我們看一下小納斯達克現在跌多少
順便看一下台期貨
其實現在期貨也不準了
有什麼不準
就破底了 隨便它漲隨便它跌
好不好
這跟大家講
我們看一下
真的真的 我是說真的
我現在內心很矛盾
我有點私心 希望破失望點
然後我賺個兩億
然後我又覺得好像你們會痛苦一點點
可是我又覺得說好像這個月
比如說接下來加入會員的人會爽到
我很矛盾 我又希望直接上去
你知道嗎
我是認真跟你講的
然後為什麼我還希望破失望點
因為我喜歡那種造神運動
你們要把我當骨神的 我覺得很爽
阿澤周 阿你怎麼賣高點
不好意思 我很多會員賺1、200%
還是很多股票賺啊
是
我還是有股票賣啊
南亞科不是有賣嗎
對不對
連發科有賣啊
賣4000多元啊
國際有賣啊
是不是
至少不會公約相聚
國際賺100%
有賣不是沒賣
你們不要這樣說
是不是
每個都要賣
哪個人都全部賣最高點
哪有可能
小鬧子阿哥現在也是破底的
你疊下去的
我不去想這件事情
好不好
得知我信
不得我命
破失望點
得知我信
因為這是我想要賺錢的點位
不得我命
沒關係
我本來就有別的部位
這是我想法
有錢的
拜託
大家大部隊
集合一下
好不好
我是折神會員朋友
跟朋友折神一起加入會員
目前朋友賺476萬
我賺146萬
我很多朋友
會員還是賺的
那既然賺的話
我就順水推舟
就散去
就像環球經營
這會員講到
有沒有看到
目前這樣一起加入會員
目前賺476萬
他賺146萬喔
買到沒錢沒關係
不要現在在這邊殺
拜託
不要現在殺
不要這樣殺
真的不要現在殺
刪除APP
你受不了刪除APP就好
真的
你想要殺的果票
先把APP給刪掉
看著著著
打開YT
看著著著你每天的節目
好不好
真的真的
你殺了你現在會後悔
7648人還不夠
明天再一根
斷頭再一根就OK
好不好
OK嗎
這個啊
我加入我也目前小規費還沒賺回來
你看也有人抱怨
可是也有人賺很多
那個就是你加入的時間點
如果你今天是年初參加的
你賺翻的
如果你是這個月參加的
比較不划算
可是如果是現在要參加呢
你賺翻的
為什麼
因為很多人
因為你現在買的比之前的人還低啊
你沒有買到1月的低點啊
不可能啊
可是你可以買的
比5月比6月的低點還低耶
所以現在參加會員的人聰明啊
聰明啊 好不好
這次是會賣美債全家0050嗎
不好意思 我就說了 我已經
我現在工作 for you
什麼意思 為你們而已啊
我才不要
我跟你講 我已經少賺兩億了
我人設已經演這麼成功了
我不要破壞我人設
什麼意思
我1.71美債
我說要賺到2200萬我才賣嘛
沒有賺到2200萬我就不賣啦
不然我說我不擔分意思
我不要啦
除非我真的想退休好不好
我不會把這個諾言改變的
上次有改變
七成五說可以賣
兩成五說我說
說我說完話
隨便啦
我不想讓別人有話講的空間
所以1.74億每次就放在那邊啦
是不是
放在那邊啦
沒差啦
我們有跟投資產的會員
根本就不怕
因為哲哲買經期滿的低
真的啊
他們都知道我盡量不追股票啊
是
我真的不追
只是我已經買很低了
有些股票還殺下去
請問位費很高嗎
你資產20萬以下
不要參加會員
20萬以上你可以打來問
好不好
OK
OK啊
哲哲我知道低低低
那是56k數據的時代
真的啦
好不好
OK
那個
在開玩笑吧
好不好
月資面托把
服了 我要跟著歐盈
有錢的趕快跟大家講
我身上剩700
你們都好笑
700有700等級嗎
有 我們有訂閱制的
不好意思 那700就算了
好不好
留著吃飯 好不好
還是700萬
世界先進
世界先進來看一下
沒關係啦 大家都開玩笑
至少大家還笑得出來
還開玩笑出來
說我只剩700元
世界先進一樣
世界先進沒有什麼不好
147.5除以223
我們看看
看看距離
147.5除以223
34% 差不多也差不多
其實我跟你講這種基優股群聯
已經回檔35%
我說35%真的可以買了
30幾% 你真的30幾%都可以買了
你不能世界線金的群聯也好
環球經驗也好
反而金材回檔比較少
你不看金材這樣漲
我們教你怎麼看回檔好不好
來 我教你看一下
你自己持股診斷一下
可是前提是要我講的基優股
或者你真的也認為基優股
310.5 來來
這是精彩嗎
對不對
418.5我幫我記一下
高點是418.5好不好
我們現在的股價
310.5
現在的股價精彩 舉例喔
除了算前波高點
除以前波最高點
418.5
你看它是0.74什麼意思
就是它是它的74則
打乘上0.74
最高點乘上0.74
等於乘上現在的股價
等於股價回答多少
回答25%
減1就知道
減1嘛
減100%
回答25%
那懂不懂
你現在的股價除上最高的股價
就是你現在剩多少
剩74%
剩74%那回答多少
用減1來算
就是回答0.25就回答25%
因為乘100就25%
回答減掉1
就是回答多少
回答25%
你現在有些基優股回檔35%可以買
那有些哪些股票
回檔35%也不一定要買
超過
來 你們去找賣隔離
跟你講一萬塊
好不好
你們去找大摩
算了 我不要這樣
他們現在壓力也很大
算了 算了 算了
我跟你講 搖持金木壓力也很大
好不好
因為有成本不同
搖持金木壓力也很大
算了 我不要
算了 這個時候我本來不要
敲人家的外資了
只是我希望年輕的外資真的
有報告不要這樣寫
大摩那個報告真的不要這樣寫
沒有什麼叫做
悲觀六百多塊
樂觀兩千塊
罵內瑕狗
不要這樣寫報告
這樣寫報告
你就算對了也沒人認為你是對的
我知道你們要看我的節目
我知道很多大戶外資在看我的節目
好 今天大家心情不好
我不要再叮人家了
好不好
我不要叮人家了
就這樣子吧
你是主動型ETF
他們壓力也很大
就那以後就買台灣50吧
好不好
如果你覺得主動型ETF
你買的也壓力大
那就買台灣50吧
當然我認為還是很多人
會買主動型ETF啦
我只告訴你
至少你這個行情
你看到我跟別人不同的地方
只剩紅海咧
紅海什麼跌的
紅海是基優股什麼跌的
你說有些股票呢
塔塔電呢
塔電不能看啦
1580 我就跟妳講
我就跟妳講
塔塔電跟國巨是一樣啦
妳哪有
妳哪有給他後年EPS
要給他40倍本益比
本來要不要120倍本益比
妳等同於現在給他60倍本益比耶
不只喔妳等同於現在給他
對 60倍本益比
60倍本益比就是很慘
塔塔電為什麼從2585
跌到1580
他回彈40%以上
我看他還會再跌
還會再跌
為什麼
他回彈40%
很簡單
因為他60倍本益比
比比
各位投資朋友
各位親愛的
親愛的
各位親愛的寶貝們
他回彈
他60倍本益比
賣腦
他要定60倍本益比
那我連買紅海
才十幾倍本益比
所以很多基優股真的好不好
今天跟大家講這些東西
所以我們看一下我們今天三大論點
一次講完
然後什麼東西
那個小孩幾分
50喔 今天講得很精彩
所以我看一下論點有沒有講完
等我一下
對
自備
中國自研半導體設備大力空
假的啦
跌破四萬二只是剛開始
有可能現在開始要斷頭了
再殺下去要斷頭了
反正破四萬點我要買
被動原件漲價
看起來是小蝦的行
好不好
現在紀錄線型沒有支撐
不用看了
可是4萬點我會支撐
我會支撐你們心
拜託你們真的你們all in
拜託你們不敢all in
拜託不要現在在這邊砍好不好
真的不要在這邊砍
你們要了解現在AI跟以前AI不同
拜託你們要有想像空間
你們要有想像空間看我
嘴嘴就知道
我真的我不拿亂砸錢的
我其實很討厭賠錢
我跟你講我進場就是要賺錢
老天爺要送錢給我花
我就花
你要不要跟我一起進場
要
你要不要
我只能買台灣我只賺那些小錢
小報酬
一堆股票到時候有機會賺一倍
玩球金我就有機會賺一倍
你要不要跟著我
歡迎來電消息 08066 8085
還有更多有人賺一倍的國票
080來勒 幫您幫我
我叫我LINE
私訊我全台灣唯一百萬粉絲的分析師就是我
全台灣唯一講過最多次
講過一百次以上 幾百次以上
叫你不要融資 要去槓桿的分析師
就是我
你去想看
你要不要賺大錢
想清楚的話趕快加我LINE
私訊我說 等著
趕快我趁這時候要加入會員
會不會多少
我接近我手來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 掰掰
谢谢大家